palais
[Musique]
ça swingue à la rencontre du cercle de
fermières la plaine dans le comté
terrebonne le député sortant michel
boudrias et sur place il fait du terrain
comme on appelle en politique et pour le
bloquiste ce genre d'événement est
primordial pour mousser sa candidature
michel boudrias a même décidé d'investir
cinq mille dollars de sa poche
il n'y a pas de soutien ou de transfert
de fonds venant par exemple du parti
chaque candidat doit mettre la main à la
pâte pour arriver à trouver une petite
cagnotte financière descente peut être
capable de livrer une campagne eurobus
de 2004 à 2015 les parties recevait de
l'argent public chaque année environ
deux dollars pour chaque vote obtenu
lors de l'élection précédente ce qui a
rapporté au bloc québécois par exemple 3
millions de dollars en 2008
mais une fois au pouvoir est majoritaire
les conservateurs ont décidé d'abolir
graduellement ce financement
je pense que c'est une dépense quand tu
peux juste fier
ironiquement ce sont les conservateurs
qui perdent alors le plus d'argent pour
compenser les parties ils décident de
hausser le montant permis d donc
aujourd'hui un électeur peut donner
jusqu'à 1600 $ par année au candidat de
son choix et un autre 1600 aux partis
conservateurs et libéraux en sorte
gagnant 1 tradition de financement
populaire qui est importante au parti
conservateur
chez les libéraux on investit beaucoup
pour développer des bases de données
comme le libéralisme par exemple pour
les solliciter des dons l'an dernier les
deux parties ont d'ailleurs voté contre
un projet de loi de michel vaudry ya
pour revenir au financement selon le
vote ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'à
l'heure actuelle le but d'avoir refusé
de rétablir le financement public des
partis politiques c'est de tuer les
tiens partie est de revenir aux vieux
système bleu rouge faisant campagne dans
tout le pays
le parti vert et le npd de leur côté
font face à un plus gros défi encore que
le bloc québécois
moi je dirais 75% des pancartes qu'on a
maintenant son dépend car de 2015
plusieurs fois candidat chez les verts
daniel green un moindre source
s'éteignent lui aussi parce que je
trouve triste c'est qu'avec de l'argent
peut acheter une démocratie des
candidats des gros partis conservateurs
libéraux gagnent dans ces élections
parce qu'ils ont plus d'argent pour un
seul donateur de 1600 dollars ou partis
verts libéraux et conservateurs en ont
probablement mille illustre le directeur
de campagne des verts au québec c'est
sain plus de 50% du budget du parti qui
a été perdu avec le financement public
et le parti a dû investir pour
et changer sa stratégie donc aller
chercher de plus en plus de donateurs
augmenter ces levées de fonds et de
nombreux candidats réussissent à
augmenter leurs budgets député sortant
du bien de [ __ ] lui aussi appauvris par le
nouveau système
mathieu dubé vise une compagne avec les
mêmes moyens qu'en 2015
mais il faut solliciter les dons c'est
malheureux c'est beaucoup de travail qui
nous et qui peut parfois nous éloigner
les acteurs on a déjà très généreux qui
nous a plu des gens de la
circonscription qui croient dans ce que
nous faisons mais c'est certain que
comme j'ai dit qu'à qu'on a des
montagnes si élevés qu'ils sont permis
par la loi
il va de soi qu'elle est parti qui
défende les mineurs qui sont les plus
avantagés matthew dubé croit qu'ottawa
devrait s'inspirer du québec qui permet
des dons de 100 dollars maximum par
personne 2 100 en année électorale
sinon pensent les tiers partis les
écarts de richesse entre partis fédéraux
vont augmenter c'est une hypothèse qui
serait très plausible cette voie encore
plus de distorsions ou 2d car un des
gens qui se battent pour la première la
deuxième place et les gens qui se
battent pour les places suivantes lors
de la campagne de 2015 libéraux et
conservateurs avait dépensé presque 40
millions de dollars de plus que le parti
vert et le bloc québécois est une
douzaine de millions de dollars de plus
que le npd
les quatre cette année s'annonce encore
plus élevé ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal